[Music]  i want  next generation eu to kick-start  a european renovation wave and make our  union a leader  in the circular economy renovation is a  win-win solution  it will reduce energy bills and improve  people's living conditions  it will create jobs and help recovery  and  it will help us to become a carbon  neutral continent by the middle  of this century the green recovery  must begin where we live work and study  we need better buildings to build back  better  our renovation wave will support  families and businesses  who want to insulate their homes and  offices green their roofs  install charging points for electric  vehicles in their garages  or heat and cool their homes with  self-generated renewable  energy